so my budget was unlimited I'd probably
go to a professional seamstress get
completely tailored and everything made
it would probably end up costing me
anywhere between 500 and a thousand five
hundred pounds into a metal worker for
that massive belt piece because that's
just gorgeous and it's such a shame to
do it in plastic exactly
thank you
some of them they're really quite high
priced ones sort of 50 to 100 and over
are stunning figures so yeah that's
probably what most of my money was on
the Lincoln Zelda the sword and shield
are the integral thanks for length so
both of those two have cost me 300
pounds in total so that's a good 99 yeah